We're given that angle ADB
is congruent to angle ADC.
So let me write that down.
So angle ADB, so that's
this angle right over here.
They're telling us that
that's congruent to ADC,
so that's this angle
right over there.
They also tell us that
angle BAD, angle bad,
so that's this angle.
I'll do it with two arcs
because it's not necessarily
the same measure
as this one here.
So angle BAD is
congruent to angle CAD.
That's angle CAD, so this is
this angle right over here.
Prove that triangle BAD-- this
is the triangle on the left--
is congruent to triangle CAD.
That's this triangle
on the right.
And so they give
the givens here.
Angle BAD is congruent to CAD.
Well, they've
already told us that.
And they also told us that
angle ADB is congruent to ADC.
So we've already marked that
up, so how do we prove this?
Well, the one thing we know,
and this is almost intuitively
obvious, is that the
measure of this segment
is equal to itself.
And the reason why
that's a useful thing
to state explicitly is because
that side, the segment AD,
is part of both triangles.
So let's just mark that there.
It's equal to itself.
So let me write this here.
And the reason why
it's useful, is
you're kind of saying, hey,
look, this is a side on both
of those triangles
that we care about.
So we could write AD
is congruent to AD,
and it would be by the
reflexive property, which
is the most obvious
property that something
is going to be equal to itself.
So reflexive property,
there you go.
But now, by stating
that we've explicitly
put up enough
information in our proof,
to now say that
the left triangle
is congruent to the right.
And the reason why
we can say that is we
have a corresponding angle,
corresponding side, and then
another corresponding
angle that is
congruent to this angle,
this side, and this angle.
And we talk about
in other videos,
about why
angle-side-angle works.
If I have one triangle that has
congruent one angle, a side,
and another angle that's
congruent to another triangle,
it's impossible for me to draw a
triangle that is not congruent.
This is a basic
axiom that we assume.
It's a basic assumption.
So now we have
enough information.
We can now write
that triangle BAD,
and we want to make sure we
have the corresponding sides.
So what corresponds to angle
B, or vertex B, right over here
is C. So it's going
to be C, and then
we'd want to go to
A and then D, CAD.
And the reason is we have an
angle, a side, and an angle.
So let me get an
angle-side-angle congruence.
There you go.
And I think we are done.
Let's see how we did.
There you go.